jean benoit est ce que vous connaissiez
jean sevilla
bien sûr jean sevilla et journaliste
critique littéraire et rédacteur en chef
adjoint au figaro magazine vous avez
fait deux livres zita impératrice
courage et le terrorisme intellectuel
qui ont bien marché quand il beaucoup de
succès et publié aujourd'hui
historiquement correct toujours chez
perrin alors appliqué à l'histoire dit
vous le politiquement correct s'appelle
l'historiquement correct c'est le nom de
votre livre alors oui dit que
l'historiquement correct finalement
c'est très intéressant c'est analyser le
passé avec les principes les critères de
notre époque
c'est là que l'on juge le passé à
travers le prisme du présent c'est ça
finalement
absolument c'est une vision de
l'histoire qui est déformé par les fêtes
les hommes d'autrefois ne peuvent être
compris que dans leur contexte 1
aujourd'hui on a tendance à analyser
dans une certaine culture médiatique un
petit peu simplifié le passé avec les
lunettes d'aujourd'hui alors mon passé
en revue l'histoire de france on va pas
ce soir évidemment faire comme ça votre
livre chapitre par chapitre
ça va de la féodalité donc à la guerre
d'algérie pas en parler de la révolution
vous parlez de la terreur vous dites que
la terreur c'est le principe totalitaire
avant la lettre que finalement
robespierre
staline c'est un peu la même chose quoi
ah oui c'était juste un clash si on met
tous les historiens maintenant qu'on
vienne la terreur et dans la révolution
je ne dis pas que la révolution ce n'est
que la terreur mais si on parle de la
révolution faut parler de droits de
l'homme je veux bien mais il faut aussi
parler la terreur et cette rupture était
grave de conséquences dans notre
histoire c'est les flots de sang la
révolution aussi mais les pays voisins
dit vous ont eu autant d'évolutions
sociales sans a besoin de la terreur
absolument sans terreur sans dictature
sans en toucher comme ça aussi j'ai
senti par une pie xii par exemple à qui
on a beaucoup reproché pendant la guerre
ne pas intervenir c'est à dire été
l'objet d'une pièce de théâtre et puis
d'un film de costa gavras avec mathieu
kassovitz qui s'appelle la mène on a
beaucoup parlé ici alors ville pendant
la guerre ni roosevelt et churchill ni
de gaulle ont accusé l'allemagne nazie
d'exterminer les juifs
c'est la vérité de l'histoire et que les
touristes vous on reproche que pie xii
de pas d'avoir fait je pense que j'étais
plus une bagarre philosophie qu'on mène
contre l'église mais rien on sait que
l'historien savent que pie xii à son
époque et avec ses moyens est intervenu
pour sauver les juifs comme là où ils le
pouvaient alors c'est la colonisation
vous notez que des gens comme jules
ferry comme léon blum proclamé à
l'assemblée nationale
j'avais envie de voir des races
supérieures d'aider les races
inférieures alors là où ça devient
jusque là disons bon mais la messe est
dite par exemple l'afrique a été
décolonisée trop tôt je ne dis pas cela
je dis que si on juge la colonisation et
la décolonisation il faut comme dans
toute l'histoire il faut dresser une
colonne avec les peluches et une colonne
avec les - et aujourd'hui on tenta à le
juger l'histoire qu'avec une seule phase
mais l'histoire a toujours fait de deux
côtés le bien le mal donc il faut tout
pesé rien n'est simple l'historiquement
correct c'est d'abord du manichéisme on
simplifie on dresse le camp du bien
quand du mal mais du bien ni mal il y en
a dans l'histoire mais il y en a dans
tous les bords alors sur l'algérie moi
c'est ce qui m'a le des parties de votre
bouquin qui sont assez facilement
accessible mais sur l'algérie quand vous
dites que l'algérie n'a pas été exploité
par la france mais qui étaient secourus
par la france oui c'est une
démonstration qui a été fait par des
historiens de l'économie et des
historiens de transition gauche
d'ailleurs on s'aperçoit on a fait les
comptes jacques marseille qu'elle
incluait de la gauche a montré que l'
empire colonial français a plus coûté à
la france qui lui a rapporté la
colonisation au départ était une idée
républicaine on voulait apporter les
droits de l'homme le progrès et il ya eu
un effort financier tout à fait
considérable ce qui ne veut pas dire
qu'il n'y a pas eu de situations
d'injustice sociale dans les colonies
ces gens on est d'accord parallèlement à
ces gens c'est vrai que la colonisation
n'est pas et j'ai une idée de gauche
parallèlement à ces gens qui ont dit on
va apporter le progrès les lumières à
tous ces peuples ce que fait débouchent
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs parallèlement à
tout ça est quand même vu des gens qui
ont fait suer le burnous c'est enfin je
veux dire c'est évident qu'il ya un
évidement je ne nie pas du tout mais
justement je dis qu'en histoire il faut
dresser une colonne puce une colonne -
je ne nie pas la colonne - mais j'ai il
faudrait pas oublier a quand même plus
parce que la colonisation a aussi
apporté un seul homme de progrès au
peuple d'outre-mer et cela il faut pas
l'oublier
vous en pensez-quoi gens mais des
bouquins de sevilla je crois que la
colonisation faut pas la juger avec nos
critères de maintenant sinon c'est
absurde mais en même temps c'est vrai
que c'est dommage de voir que la france
dans un certain nombre de pays et bien
rapporter à la fois beaucoup rapporté
cette idée de liberté
cette idée d'universalisme et je suis ta
maman le vietnam
non je cite ces gens qui au vietnam les
paysans qui faisait voir les soldats
français prisonnier avec cao bang et ils
en disaient vive la france quand même
gérard ça vous semble aujourd'hui vous
trouvez ça vous dit ça y est c'est la
droite décomplexée c'est la droite qui
revient revente est close nous expliquer
que l'algérie finalement c'était c'est
la france qui tendait la main alors
qu'en fait ils sont allés là-bas pour
presser comme des êtres humains alors
donner l'éducation nécessaire mais et
vos pas et comme des espèces d'esclaves
et de il faut pas que c'est toujours
soumis intellectuellement vêtements ça
c'est un type même du propos
historiquement correct excusez moi c'est
à dire vous simplifiez vous simplifiez
dire l'histoire et c'est aujourd'hui
non je ne vais pas de sa course et je
n'en fais comme on dit est juste âgé de
dix neuf d'ailleurs c'est pas moi qui le
dit ce sont les historiens ont déjà fait
parler les spécialistes historiens là
bien sûr il ya des gens qui travaillent
qui recherche de toutes opinions soit
une fois et le bruit des chercheurs
entre le fruit de recherches et va
souvent à l'encontre des idées reçues
cette histoire est le lieu même de la
complexité on ne peut pas faire ni
d'humanité nice manie de l'anachronisme
de ce2 que de ce que qu'on donne au jeu
direct et échanger de lecture c'est vrai
je le dirai aux accords et essayer je
vois des gens toujours il ya toujours
deux parties le front toujours des gens
qui sont pour la monarchie doses qui
sont la révolution et on dirait ça
continue to 19e et 20e siècles ils ont
passé leur temps se bagarrer et en même
temps ils rêvent de se rassembler sur un
idéal que votre chat ou filmo iso depuis
longtemps mais il ya les rouspéteur des
gens qui sont recherchés pierrot qui
sont reste on est pour la religion c'est
un débat permanent en france
et si ce qui crée un peu cette source
d'instabilité et ce charme même temps ce
charme parce que tout est toujours mis
en question tout excuser mais qu'est ce
que vous en pensez
moi je pense que dans des couveuses
décolonisation et c'est surtout mal
passé dans les pays où on est resté très
longtemps et notamment les pays où
l'armée est parti et où elle fait rester
par exemple là ça se passe pas très bien
donc je suis pas trop d'accord avec vous
il ya
quand on apporter quoi qu'est-ce qu'on
avait alors apporté aussi intéressant on
apporter des progrès techniques ont
apporté des progrès sanitaires on
apporter un immense progrès qui était la
lutte contre l' esclavage la lutte
contre l'esclavagé en afrique était un
des effets paradoxaux de la colonisation
bien que l' esclavage qui est un fléau
terrible n'est pas complètement disparu
en afrique mais les européens ont tâché
de buter contre la guerre contre l'
esclavage
il y à il y à il y à un acquis bien
résister réalisation ce qui n'enlève pas
ce qui n'enlève pas s'efface donc je
n'ai jamais dit le contraire
genre je lançais dire je vous ai une
question est-ce que vous pensez que si
les pays colonisateurs à commencer par
la france qui n'a pas du tout le même
type de colonisation que l'angleterre
qu'il est plus marchande la france une
cotisation culturel sanitaire etc
est-ce que vous pensez que si ces
pays-là avait été colonisés jusqu'à
aujourd'hui
est-ce qu'ils auraient un niveau de vie
meilleure ou non sa chance au cul pour
leur bien ben c'est ce que je lui
demande voilà pour la course que je
pense que si l'afrique n'avait pas été
colonisée par exemple je pense qu'elle
n'aurait pas connu le niveau qu'elles
avaient qui était le sien en 1960 c'est
à peu près certains parfois c'était en
place et s'est replacé par les grandes
compagnies pétrolières par les grands
trusts et croyez vous qu'on l'a vu aux
ligériens
croyez vous que ce soit un fait rare de
finalement bon finalement ce pays
comme d'hab' qui n'ont plus
de résistance finalement sont
complètement exploité son il ya qu à
voir à la fois d'énergie et à
l'occupation haut niveau c'est ça la
réalité
vous savez ce qu'est l'afrique dans
l'histoire c'est que le plus fort bouffe
le plus faible
et ça c'est affreux et quand on sait pas
on voit bien les américains étaient
contre la colonisation française en
indochine
ils ont remplacé les français
d'indochine etc
et c'est pareil maintenant voilà en
afrique mais que dans certains domaines
la france a apporté des idées une idée
qui est mon avis est belle c'est l'idée
de liberté dans des pays qui quelquefois
n'avais pas l'idée même si leur part du
droit de parler
c'est une jour donner des leçons à des
pays qui ont des cultures millénaires en
leur imposant notre vision de la liberté
dans la démo d'avoir une dictature en
algérie aujourd'hui ça ne paraît pas est
une dictature millénaire donc je crois
que l'important je suis partout autant
je suis pas pour la colonisation loin de
là je pense que le drame c'est que on a
fini la colonisation et qu'on en a
retrouvé une autre est une des
dictatures terrible parce qu'il n'y a
pas eu la capacité à construire des
états forts qui permettent justement
d'avoir une indépendance minimum ce soit
sans l'accord des nations le cannabis
est sergent vous êtes le bon nom
ducasse et la culpabilisation permanente
des logis la fait pas l'apologie d'abord
donné envie du casio marica tueur est
l'hôte d'honneur l'immigration
c'est tellement faisait seller s'occuper
de leur culture de leur jeunesse
et bien ne les piller ensuite on fera
des parcs canada sunny side maison c'est
bon la fin si si quand même quand même
une relation extraordinaire voyez
comment vous transformer les choses mais
vous c'est cette année mais ne le dites
pas à ma mère voulait pas qu'on a il
bouffe et après conscience à cela parce
que là on si l'ivoirien georges jean
sevilla est ce qui manque au fait est ce
que vous faites j'enseigne à ce que vous
faites du révisionnisme sûrement pas des
barres cgt ni négationnisme mais que
tout le monde mélange les deux
révisionnisme sait réviser l'histoire
oui dans ce sens là mais enfin j'ai
appris à l'ambiguïté sur sur le terme
dans le livre que j'ai publié je fais
parler
les historiens moi je ne suis pas un
spécialiste de tous les sujets que j'ai
traité dans ce livre je suis critique
littéraire je suis historien j'ai moi
même les propres à former dans celui je
donne la parole aux chercheurs il y à
150 je cite 150 historiens aujourd'hui
jean france ils sont des gens qui
travaillent les résultats de leurs
recherches détruisent incendies des
reçus de celles qu'on entend au café du
commerce où trop souvent malheureusement
à la télévision
vous êtes là
ça n'a aucune importance à peine 2 sinon
ils ont eu à peine le magnen oui ils
paient pas les citer tous deux fermés
jeudi
c'est pour [ __ ] des appels heures avec
leur candidat rappelle nicolas quoi s'il
revient de nicolas nicolas a finalement
vu que tu reviennes nico
[Musique]
sévèrement d'armand il veut pas que tu
pars et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
de nos latitudes abonnez vous y mettez
un peu de bleu